[Musique]
borgès et le clézio enfin apostrophe
enfin parce qu'il ya bien longtemps que
je rêvais de vous les présenter et par
le plus grand des hasards du voici tous
les deux dans la même émission
je rappelle que ce genre d'entretien
s'adresse surtout à ceux qui ont la
chance de ne pas connaître encore et de
ne pas avoir lu encore ces deux
écrivains jeudi la chance parce que de
tous les plaisirs celui de la découverte
m'a toujours paru être le plus excitant
voici le 250e numéro d' apostrophes
consacrer d'abord à jmg le clézio et
ensuite à changer luis borgès
oui
comme je vous le disais la semaine
dernière le clézio a déjà son nom dans
tous les dictionnaires une importante
que 40 ans mais en dix sept ans il a
publié 14 livres traduits dans le monde
entier et qui ont fait de lui le
meilleur écrivain français de sa
génération
en 1963 il obtenu le prix renaudot avec
son premier livre son premier roman
procès verbal et on a su tout de suite
ce serait un écrivain important cause de
son style à cause de sa sensibilité son
intelligence et depuis n'a cessé de
raconter dans une langue simple belle
que m'inspirait il n'a cessé de raconter
à la fois les beautés et les pièges
desalination du monde moderne pour le
clézio l'homme est encombrant c'est un
rapace est la première victime de ce
rapace s'est lui-même bay en chacun de
nous un désir de pureté un désir
d'absolu
l'enfance est un paradis perdu et nous
ne se sent de progrès t de l'avoir perdu
est ce pour autant que le clézio d'un
mystique en tout cas c'est un écrivain
qui fuit les micros et les caméras
et ce n'est pas un hasard si dans son
dernier roman il fait l'éloge du silence
de la soif et du désert faut-il vous
appeler jean marie gustave le clézio ou
jmg le clézio comme il est indiqué sur
la couverture de vos livres
c'est comme vous voulez je vais bien
vous m'appeliez j'aime j'aime beaucoup
mangé l'occasion parce que je trouve ça
fait un peu non de voitures de motos
j'ai une jmg le clézio font ça très très
beau et comme on a souvent parlé des
voitures et c'est un nom de passeport
d'un an de passeport oui c'est à dire
que j'ai un passeport mauricien et sur
mon passeport maurice écrit jmg le
clézio on ne met pas le prénom mais les
initiales dans votre premier roman le
procès-verbal personnage principal qui
s'appelait adam paulo vivait dans une
villa sur la côte d'azur il en sortait
rarement mes temps en temps il écrivait
sur son papier sur son paquet de
cigarettes il écrivait que notation à la
fois pour une sorte d de mémoire et un
temps de journal intime un peu bizarre
là lui notait acheter à manger le papier
journaux et puis ils n'étaient pas cette
formule faire un effort pour voir le
monde
j'ai l'impression que je aujourd'hui
parce que je sais que je craignais
beaucoup les caméras que vous faites un
petit peu un effort pour pourvoir du
monde on pourrait être vu par le monde
oui mais c'est la même chose
oui c'est un petit peu la même chose non
ce n'est pas que je crains les caméras
mais simplement que je pense qu'il ne
faut pas ne faut pas trop parler il ne
faut pas trop s'expliquer c'est pourquoi
parce que on risque de ne pas dire
exactement ce qu'on voulait dire et on
risque un petit peu de
de ne pas être exact d'inventer
l'écriture est bien supérieure pour ça
parce que on ne se laisse pas emporter
par les mots quand on écrit me contrôler
oui mais comment gagner des gens à
l'écriture comment faire lire
jmg le clézio si nous n'avons pas de
temps en temps une interview dans la
presse écrite un entretien à la radio ou
à la télévision
oui enfin je pense que c'est sympa
surtout par le parent melli je crois
qu'on un écrivain est connu surtout
parce qu'il a des filles par tellement
parce qu'il fait ou parce que oui alors
je commence cet entretien à mon avis
d'une très mauvaise façon parce que oui
je fais référence à votre premier livre
le procès-verbal dire que je fais et à
un petit peu de ma culture je sais que
ça vous agace beaucoup car c'est vrai
qu'il ya quelque chose d'un peu
redondant sorte de duel entre eux entre
vous et moi j'ai l'impression de vous
dire bon vous avez écrit niveau lire
mais moi je les ai lus alors au fond je
suis aussi fort que vous et ça je sais
que cela vous agace un peu peut-être pas
tort m'agace pas mais je pense que un
écrivain et nouveaux à chaque fois qu'il
fait un livre c'est à dire que je n'ai
pas un nouveau livre c'est un peu un
nouvel écrivain à chaque fois on est
nouveau chaque fois qu'on écrit un
nouveau lieu alors voyons le nouveau jmg
le clézio dans ce livre magnifique qui
s'intitule désert c'est une double
histoire pour raconter une histoire qui
se passe d'abord en 1909 1910 et puis
une autre de nos jours alors celle de 19
points 117 est au fond un épisode de la
guerre coloniale que vous racontez oui
je n'ai pas vu cela comme ça pour moi
c'est la fascination pour un personnage
un chèque
mauritanien avec s'appelait mining qui
vivait donc à cette époque là et qui
était un des derniers nomades c'était un
des derniers sauvages les derniers
hommes qui étaient séparés de la culture
les villes de la culture de ce qu'on
appelle la civilisation et qui a lutté
contre les français des espagnols les
anglais les allemands qui cherchait à
imposer une culture de ville une culture
une civilisation sens romain d'animaux
alors c'est un petit peu cette parabole
qui m'a qui m'a plu dima el-horr ce
grand cheikh fabuleuse miraculeux aussi
falsifié beaucoup de miracles va mourir
avec tous les hommes bleus qu'il dirige
guerre sauvage puis il faut dire par les
troupes françaises
aidés de quelques les troupes
tirailleurs sénégalais comme on disait
autrefois
et puis parallèlement à cette histoire
est l'histoire d'une jeune fille qui
s'appelle la lah et qui est né de
l'autre côté la méditerranée dans un
bidonville mais proche du désert et elle
va comment la menace de se marier avec
un homme qu'elle n'aime pas elle fuit
dans le désert avec un jeune homme qui
ne parle pas et qui est un descendant
des hommes bleus de ce don avait raconté
l'épopée bon pourquoi ne va pas jusqu'au
bout du désert avec lui parce que ce
n'est pas possible
c'est un voyage trop difficile trop dur
à ne survit pas à ne pourrait pas
survivre dans le désert n'est pas
préparés alors la voilà maintenant à
marseille
oui ensuite elle devient une
travailleuse immigrée que mon histoire
actuellement et elle travaille dans un
hôtel elle fait des ménages elle fait
des travaux très bas et puis en même
temps elle attend un enfant de ce ce
berger avec lesquels et s'étaient enfuis
puis elle rencontre un photographe et
elle devient une sorte de une sorte de
chimère une sorte de fantaisie de ses
photographes qui exploite un petit peu
son image et ça l'amusé ailleurs ici
pendant un certain temps puis tout à
coup elle en a assez
elle retourne vers le désert l'espère
fuir au fond elle ce fut elle-même fils
à ce qu'elle est cherche à retrouver son
passé et retourne elle retourne vers le
désert dans l'espoir de pouvoir enfin
s'ils s'y intégrer le personnage
principal de ce livre c'est évidemment
le désert
quelles sont les vertus du désert je
pense que c'est surtout la l'espace la
liberté c'est le sentiment d'être libre
c'est quelque chose de très très fort et
qui manque beaucoup
la civilisation actuelle tout à l'heure
je me promenais sur les bords de la
seine et j'ai été frappé par une
inscription qui étaient des gens ils
dorment dehors ont inscrit
quelqu'un avait écrit je suis encore
libres sur le sur le quai de la seine et
ça m'a frappé comme d'un homme a besoin
véritable besoin profond de l'être
humain actuellement de la êtres
civilisés de lettres urbain on est à
paris et quelquefois on a encore le
sentiment de cette liberté cette
possibilité de liberté alors je pense
que le désert c'est ça c'est cette
possibilité de liberté c'est on est
libre dans le désert bref il n'y a pas
de frontières le désert c'est par
excellence pays qu'on ne divise pas ça
n'appartient à personne
et puis c'est un pays où il ya une telle
intensité de lumière une telle intensité
devant enfin les éléments principaux de
la terre qui sont le vent la lumière le
ciel sont visibles sont infinies oui
mais il y à l'absence d'eau et combien
de fois vous parlez de la soie recettes
soir terribles de ces guerriers bleus
qui remonte des airs et qui meurent de
soif
oui mais ce que la soif c'est une
atteinte à la liberté je ne crois pas il
me semble que les civilisations les plus
les plus prenantes les plus
extraordinaires ont été façonnés par la
soif ont été façonnés par le manque que
ce soit quand ce qu'on se dit soif je
veux dire soif de tout le manque de
moyens de subsistance
il vaut mieux un angle qu'abondance fois
que les civilisations les plus
extraordinaires soient les civilisations
naumann soit civilisation comme celle du
peuple maya au mexique sont des
civilisations qui ont été faites par ce
besoin d'autre chose ce besoin de
trouver quelque chose
trouver nourriture au même abondance
tout simplement je demande ce passage de
votre livre personne n'avait oublié la
fin là c'est la fin soit la soirée afin
qu'ils rongent non seulement la fin des
aliments mais toute la fin la fin des
spas de libération la fin de tout ce qui
manquait creuse vertige sur le sol la
faim qui pousse en avant dans le nuage
de poussière au milieu des troupeaux et
bt la fin qui fait gravir la pente des
collines jusqu'au point où il faut
redescendre avec devant soi des dizaines
des centaines d'autres colis identique
cette fin au fond c'est de faire cette
soif que la lave à rechercher violement
voyez c'est la possibilité de se trouver
soi même dans la difficulté que l'on a
avec le monde lorsque le monde est
facile lorsqu'il vous offre comme c'est
le cas dans les civilisations urbaines
où il offre à tous l'eau et au robinet
nourriture et chez le marchand
il n'y a pas de on n'a pas ce sentiment
de la réalité donc ce sentiment de la
liberté puisque la liberté c'est
peut-être intégrer un paysage être
intégré à la terre se trouver en contact
avec le monde il ya aussi d'autres
vertus du désert celle-ci il était plein
d'une autre force d'un autre temps qui
l'avait rendu étrangers à l'ordre des
hommes peut-être qu'il n'attendait plus
rien qui ne savait plus rien et qu'il
était devenu semblable au désert silence
immobilité absence et et si un mot qui
revient très souvent sur les plumes
c'est le mot silence
oui parce que je crois que c'est une des
vertus fondamentales de l'homme de
pouvoir justement de pouvoir terre en
lui tout ce qui nuirait à la beauté
monde extérieur il a cette possibilité
de devenir silencieux de de ressembler
aux paysages qu'ils aiment ce mois
encore faut-il qu'ils trouvent ce
paysage c'est difficile à trouver ce
genre de paysage de lille oui enfin
c'était pas vraiment difficile mais
c'est difficile d'y vivre parce que la
société urbaine dont on parlait société
de la civilisation justement vous impose
cette habitude du bruit il faut faire du
bruit
il faut faire du bruit et faire entendre
du bruit c'est à dire faire partie du
cycle du bruit consommer et donner du
mou y
oui mais nous est très bien qu'il ya des
silences terrifiant beaucoup plus utile
beaucoup plus considérables que des
tumultes si grand soit il c'est vrai oui
c'est vrai même dans les villes il y en
a il ya il ya des des endroits à paris
mais mon sens est ce poids de silence
très étrange mais c'est généralement
sous terre par y consentent
c'est pour ton passe dans les tunnels
sous les ponts de la seine certains
endroits mais est-ce que vous même vous
n'êtes pas tenté par cette évasion vers
le silence dans l'immobilité
oui c'est contradictoire parce que
j'écris et écrire c'est aussi faire du
bruit évidemment même les mots écrits
sur du papier font du bruit alors il ya
cette contradiction c'est un fait mais
je crois que il ya une possibilité même
à travers les mots d'arrivée je dirais
presque exprimer ce quart entre les mots
c'est à dire exprimer ce que les mots ne
disent pas il me semble que l'essentiel
de la littérature
enfin ce que j'aime dans la littérature
c'est ce qu'elle dit en dehors des mots
à côté des mots si elle laisse entendre
à côté des mots qui composent il en
ruines silence ça s'entend bien sûr ça
fait même au bout de moi oui ça peut
être une pression très forte sur sur
l'âme elle attend c'est tout
il s'agit de la latence et tous les gens
beaucoup de patience peut être qu'ils
attendent toute leur vie quelque chose
et que jamais rien arrivé
effectivement le désert c'est un lieu où
on attend mais on attend qu'on espère
quoi rien oui il ya aussi une vertu de
la tente quelque chose
de fondamental savoir attendre savoir
perdre donc perdre son temps ne pas
avoir un temps complet mais pouvoir
attendre plusieurs mois plusieurs
semaines que quelque chose arrive et ne
pas attendre vraiment que quelque chose
se produise mais attendre simplement
sans but c'est à dire être là un peu
comme une pierre ou comme un animal qui
qui se reposent qui a fui à son esprit
au repos oui mais les guerriers bleus
qui remonte dr pourchassé par les
troupes françaises
ils attendent et espèrent ils espèrent
du terrain pour cultiver pour les
experts des nourritures de la boisson
ils ne sont pas dans la tente de rien
oui mais c'est ça aussi une d une des
choses extraordinaires je crois du
désert c'est que c'est occupés par des
hommes et souvent même par des animaux
qui se déplace dans l'espoir de fuir le
désert et qui s'y trouvent toujours
parce que c'est très difficile c'est
c'est un territoire ingrat il faut donc
fuir il faut aller au devant ne peut pas
rester puisque on ne peut pas faire
pousser des plantes on ne peut pas vivre
du sol donc on est poussé en avant par
la soif par la faim et par l'espoir de
trouver quelque chose tout en sachant
pratiquement de façon certaine que l'on
ne trouvera rien donc c'est un espoir
sont-ce enfin l'espoir qui ne se
terminent pas l'explication
enfin c'est honteux qu'il en ait besoin
d'une mauvaise explication loup plutôt
le meilleur commentaire que j'ai trouvé
de votre livre des aides je devais dans
l'autre livre sur les trois villes
saintes qui paraît en même temps et je
vous lire ce passage cjd séparer il se
sait quoi les séparer c'est une secte de
c'est une secte une maille à des indiens
mayas qui se sont séparés se sont
séparés des autres maya hilal et mayaki
ceux qui ont accepté la colonisation
donc là on peut dire la sédentarisation
et ceux qui n'ont pas accepté ce qu'ils
n'ont pas accepté ce sont les séparer
comme les guerriers bleus oui c'est cela
c'est un peu le même si son décès m'a
réussi
hélas là aussi elles se séparent elle
même à la fin elle refuse la cette
civilisation qu'on veuille imposer au
lit tricheur alors les séparer les
séparer et c'est super les séparer n'ont
pas fermé leurs yeux ils ont gardé leurs
regards en vie tandis qu'autour d'eux
les étrangers s'endormait maintenant la
guerre est finie
où sont les vaincus les hommes qui
ressemble à la terre les hommes qui sont
pareils aux arbres les hommes qui ont la
peau couleur de terre les femmes qui ont
la peau couleur de maïs ceux qui ne
vivent que par le pain et l'eau ne sont
jamais vaincu ce ne sont pas les
richesses qu'ils désirent ni le pouvoir
sur les terres étrangères
ils ne cherchent que l'ordre du monde
qu'ils habitent comme cela obstinément
par le seul pouvoir du regard et de la
parole c'est l'explication vous
semble-t-il du désert wild ailleurs le
pays où ce s'est passé là ce qu'on a
appelé la guerre des castes puisque je
me les trois villes saintes retrace un
épisode de la guerre des castes le
dernier épisode de la guerre des castes
c'est un pays qui ressemble un petit peu
au désert africain
c'est un désert calcaire minérales avec
quelques broussailles comme c
le cas dans le rio de oro se passe le
récit du désert mais qu'est ce qui leur
est arrivé à ces trois villes saintes
qui celle qui se nomme changchun pomme
et jusqu'à qu'elles sont situées où
elles sont situées dans l'est du yucatan
et licata se situe où vous savez yucatan
se situe c'est une péninsule est au sud
est du mexique non la mer des caraïbes
qu'est ce qui leur est arrivé à cette
rapide et bien ce sont les trois villes
qui ont dans lesquelles se sont
retrouvés les guerriers qui s'appelait
les guerriers de la croix c'était des
croisés qui ont lutté contre tout
d'abord contre les espagnols puis contre
les mexicains contre le gouvernement
mexicain et qui se sont comme on le
disait séparés parce qu'il n'acceptait
pas la colonisation il voulait chasser
les blancs du mexique il voulait faire
un empire indien et ils se sont donc
croiser parce qu'ils pensaient être les
vrais chrétiens y penser que les autres
n'étaient pas des chrétiens parce que
justement ce n'étaient pas des hommes
exemplaires s'étaient c'était des
commerçants c'étaient des hommes qui
étaient un petit peu qu'ils n'avaient
pas ces sept vertus que considéré avoir
et en se séparant ils se sont ils ont
fondé une une ville en se croisant ils
ont fondé une ville s'appelait john
santa cool c'est à dire la petite sandra
cause
et là ils ont ils ont lutté pendant
50-60 ans avec l'aide de contrebandiers
anglais avec toutes sortes de moyens et
ils ont été vaincus vers 1940
c'est à dire ya assez peu de temps et
lorsqu'on a pris leur ville churn santa
cruz sont réunis dans ces trois villes
saintes où ils ont continué à exercer le
culte de la croix c'est à dire une sorte
de culte chrétiens mais les deux rites
hindous jeune femme chose assez étrange
mais vous savez que beaucoup de
critiques littéraires français qui vous
classe plus ou moins parmi les mystiques
en dix ans le clézio finalement c'est un
mystique
oui je ne sais pas ce que ça veut dire
vraiment mystique
enfin je je vois ce que ça peut vouloir
dire cela peut dire quelqu'un qui est
passionné par les expériences parler les
vertus religieuses par la religion par
la foi quelle que soit la fois lorsque
des hommes qui sont justement dans une
situation très difficile comme les mayas
ou comme les hommes bleus du désert sont
animés par la foi et cette fois l'effet
surmonter lors de leurs souffrances
leurs leur faiblesse physique et leur
fait surmonter le désert et la soif la
faim est bien c'est qu'il a qu'une chose
de passionnant dans cette fois il ya
quelque chose très fort mais je pense à
cette histoire très belle que vous
racontez dans le désert ce guerrier qui
est aveugle qui remonte tout le désert
et départ l'enfant
et puis lorsqu'il arrive au but il
rencontrera lé il demande aux grands
cheikhs de le
de guérir de lui redonner la vue et il
la recouvre cette lui et quelques heures
après il meurt massacrés par les troupes
coloniales
oui c'est un fait c'est un homme qui a
été justement qui a pu marcher qu'à pu
surmonter sa souffrance à cause de la
foi donc qui connaît une expérience
mystique et qui accorde tellement de
pouvoir a ce chèque que le miracle est
possible je crois que le miracle c'est
la rencontre d'un homme qui est mû par
une fois extraordinaire avec un autre
être extraordinaire dont la dont le
pouvoir spirituel est très très fort ce
moment là il ya le miracle quand je
recherche les commun dénominateur à tous
vos livres
jmg le clézio celui qui vient de suite à
l'esprit c'est la déambulation en effet
est que ce soit dans paulo aux premiers
personnages où tous les personnages du
désert en passant par d'autres
personnages de la guerre personnages des
géants ce sont des hommes surtout mais
les femmes aussi et qui marche kifaya
bond qui déambulent que ce soit en ville
que ce soit dans le désert j'aime
marcher cet homme sait au moins que non
seulement le plaisir mais un moyen de
connaître vraiment un endroit puis je
pense que c'est un petit peu là que
vient mon goût pour des héros qui marche
me sens bien
dans la marche une sorte de de
reconnaissance on prend contact vraiment
avec le sol avec ce qui nous entoure
et puis le rythme de la marche est plus
lent et vous permet de bien voir ce qui
se passe autour de vous donc c'est un
moyen de connaissance de du monde de
connaissance de soi même et souvent de
connaissance des autres quand on regarde
les gens marcher en dessous on se rend
compte de ce qu'ils valent
où est ce qu'ils sont avant tout il est
jugé pas les juger mais on on a une
impression qui est distrait différence
d'ailleurs nous aurions peut-être pu
faire cette rencontre en marchant aurait
été sûrement différent ouais mais akalé
dans le désert oui peut-être parce qu'à
paris en effet c'est un peu difficile
il ya aussi quelque chose qui qui m'a
plu crois beaucoup impressionné quand
j'étais petit c'est laid les picards au
lait est ce qu'on appelle le roman
picaresque et surtout le lazaret
auditors mais ce qui est un
un livre où effectivement en marche
beaucoup les personnages ne reste pas
longtemps sont des vagabonds bien
entendu et les personnages se déplacent
il ya une sorte d' aventure qui se fait
une aventure minimum en fait une
aventure quand même qui se fait parce
que les personnages changent d'endroit
qui le qui se promène dans la rue qu'il
voit autour de ce qui se passe une sorte
de de progression dans don dans la pile
dans le monde qui se fait par le dans la
marche autres comme un émulateur la
présence des enfants pendant tous vos
livres en tout cas dans les derniers
dans des airs bien sûr mais dans les
deux précédents on a connu sur la terre
dans mon dos pourquoi tous ces enfants
voient peut-être que c'est justement la
conséquence de la marche parce que la
période de la vie on marche le plus
c'est quand on est enfant on fait des
très grandes distances souvent pas très
grande en fait mais on a l'impression de
faire des très grandes distances
même la ville est une aventure pour un
enfant qui suit des sentiers qui
découvrent des passages qui découvre des
choses que les adultes ne voit plus il
ya cette possibilité justement parce que
l'enfant n'est pas motorisé parce qu'il
n'est pas mécanisée parce que lille est
encore un petit peu à l'état nature
c'est l'élément naturel dans la vie
actuelle il ya cette possibilité de
mener les enfants aujourd'hui marche de
moins en moins ils ne rêvent que de
grimper sur des motos deux enfants veut
dire jusque vers 7-8 ans nous sommes
quand même qui ne marche pas mal
position pas de moto vous étiez cet
enfant qui cherchait des passages oui
oui enfin je me souviens vraiment
d'avoir vécu des aventures dont dans la
ville de nice n'est pas une ville
spécialement fait pour l' aventure mais
il y avait des à l'époque beaucoup de
petits sentiers les chemins des
escaliers
descoings que je trouvais que je
reconnais c'est à ce moment mais vous
êtes resté aussi cet homme qui cherche
des passages que que ce soit en amérique
où vous habitez souvent mexique à
l'amérique latine
les jeunes justement ces pays là parce
que ce sont des pays où il ya encore des
sentiers enfin il est encore la
possibilité surtout au mexique deux de
partir dans la montagne de suivre des
les routes ou ne passent pas les
voitures d'aller à pied justement de
vivre un petit peu cette aventure
d'enfance qui consiste à suivre les
sentiers découvrir des choses que l'on
ne soupçonnait pas et puis ce que
j'appellerais faut le dire avec force la
communion j'insiste sur ce mot la
communion avec la vie oui là aussi je
crois que c'est un thème enfantin il me
semble que sont les enfants qui ont
cette possibilité d'être en communion
avec le monde avec l'existence c'est à
dire de ne pas voir dans les animaux et
dans les arbres un décor mais de voir
des êtres les personnes de pouvoir
parler à un arbre par les un animal il
me semble que ça c'est quelque chose de
très très important c'est beaucoup plus
fort que ça en a l'air parce que
l'enfant ne se contente pas d'inventer
un univers à sa mesure il cherche à
s'adapter aux forces extérieures il est
quelquefois terroriser et terrifié ou et
quelquefois pris d'une passion pour des
choses que nous ne voyons plus que nous
ne sentons plus alors il me semble que
je me semble que c'est ce que l'on peut
essayer de faire on a retrouvé cette
communion s'est retrouvé l'enfant qui a
la possibilité de la possibilité de
parler aux arbres et aux animaux et puis
alors à l'opposé de cette communion avec
la vie la vraie vie avec la nature avec
les arbres il y a exprimé très fortement
une sorte de n2
une civilisation que je ne s'est
qualifiée peut-être de marchands de
civilisation du profit en tout cas lan
de l'argent dans tous vos livres
oui ce sont des choses que j'ai senti
petit à petit je crois qu'il y à il ya
quelques années je n'aurais pas dit cela
et quelques années il me semble que
j'étais en gt sensible davantage là ce
qui pouvait y avoir de beaux dans les
villes friable il ya des beautés dans
les villes et merveilleusement décrit
les supermarchés les autoroutes la
possibilité d'une aventure dans ce monde
là mais je crois que c'est au fur et à
mesure qu'on le connaît on voit que
c'est de plus en plus restreint c'est à
dire que les possibilités de sentiers
qu'il ya dans les supermarchés et dans
le monde des villes ces possibilités là
sont de plus en plus restreinte
on est de plus en plus dans un monde qui
est programmé organisé qui est fait pour
être rentable moi je me souviens quand
j'ai lu votre livre les géants
vous m'avez fait aimer les supermarchés
que je n'aime pas du tout et vous mais
avait rendu jeudi pas sympathique mais
je dirais attirant alors avouer que
c'est un peu bizarre vous disiez des
choses comme ça aujourd'hui
il est certain que la vie devient de
plus en plus difficile de ce point de
vue c'est à dire que la possibilité
d'aimer les choses de devil est de plus
en plus restreint on est de plus en plus
heurté de plus en plus
soumis à ces à cette agression du monde
urbain de l'organisation du monde urbain
c'est vraiment dur ben ça peut être
aussi une jungle ça peut être une
aventure
mais si il est organisé pour être
rentable et si le supermaché n'est pas
un endroit de promenade mais devient un
endroit où le vous êtes forcé ans que je
sorte à acheter vahid à ces deux de
tendance mais c'était un endroit surtout
règne l'argent le supermarché
oui oui c'est un temple de l'argent et
je n'oublie pas que lala lorsqu'elle
quitte la gloire par la photographie
elle ne prend pas d'argent enfin leur
prend le minimum elle abandonne la large
en intéresse pas et ainsi les cavaliers
de des cavaliers bleus du désert
oui l'argent n'a aucun sens non dans le
désert l'argent n'a aucun sens c'est
bien évident l'argent ne peut pas
acheter l'eau puisqu'il n'y a pas d'eau
l'argent ne peut rien donner
mais est-ce qu'il ne considérait pas que
en ville ici à paris l'argent a trop de
sens oui sûrement l'argent a trop de
sens alors les la chose qui peut être
faite le l'effort que l'on peut faire
c'est d'aller contre l'argent
c'est-à-dire de comment vivre une
aventure dans une ville sans argent
comment faire et bien comme c'est sans
doute comme ces gens qui écrivent sur
les bords de la seine je suis encore
libres peut-être
on peut en effet être encore libres
comme cela et c'est peut-être le même
qui tend la main aux passants oui c'est
possible en effet et riffs ah oui vous
avez raison
weiss et c'est difficile dans les villes
c'est plus facile en effet au désert
mais à propos de mendiants et dans les
beaucoup question dans le désert
cette sorte de cour des miracles
composent le quartier du panier à
marseille
oui je crois que dans dans la société
actuelle il y a il ya une contre société
une société en dessous une société ce
qu'on appelle les marginaux et on fait
ce sont des c est peut-être ce cas de
sont parmi les gens les plus émouvants
les plus intéressants de la société
parce qu'ils sont en vie vivent une
révolte continuelles contre la société
urbaine contre le révolte qui n'est pas
toujours assumé jusqu'au bout puisque
quelquefois il ya des faux mendiants
parmi les mendiants en raison des gens
tout de même assez intéressant et ils
sont intéressants aussi parce qu'ils
aident à conserver intactes les vieux
quartiers et où le panier à marseille
qui est un vieux quartier a survécu
pendant assez longtemps qu'il
appartenait justement à ceux à cet autre
monde ce monde différent du monde de
l'argent et puis le jeu on a réussi à
éliminer ces gens là le quartier a été
menacée ne pensez pas que beaucoup de
téléspectateurs qui vous écoutent en ce
moment se disent mais au fond le clézio
c'est un personnage qui refuse
complètement le même notre mode de vie
d'aujourd'hui qui refusent cette société
dans laquelle nous vivons et qui par
réaction est donc réactionnaire nous
prêchent le désert nous prêchent un
monde d'autrefois
oui on peut dire ça évidemment mais
c'est une réaction qui est peut-être
scène enfin je ne sais pas mais me
semble qu'elle peut être nécessaire je
suis intéressé tout de même par les
sociétés ou pour prendre cet exemple la
mendicité est autorisé et je m'aperçois
qu'en france elle est de moins en moins
autorisée elle se fait elle continue à
se faire heureusement mais elle est de
moins en moins acceptée alors que vous
avez des quantités de société où le
mendiant fait partie du paysage
quotidien on l'admet parfaitement et
même où chacun lui donne quelque chose
c'était une sorte de métier d'être
mendiants à je crois même c'est
davantage le mendiant est le même celui
qui donne son opinion dans les grandes
occasions
qui presque un éveilleur de conscience
par lui ça sera un éveilleur de
conscience parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
sociétés où ils représentent la part
divine c'est à dire la présence de dieu
parmi nous dieu vient réclamer son dû et
il faut lui donner une petite pièce ne
faut pas l'oublier mais ce qui est vrai
c'est que on sent la présence de dieu
parmi les hommes bleus du désert alors
qu'on ne sent pas tellement parmi les
gens qui vont dans les supermarchés oui
justement parce que c'est une société où
il est interdit d'être exalté où il est
interdit d'être un mendiant il est
interdit d'être un vagabond il sera
peut-être bientôt interdit de marcher à
pied lorsque ça devient
en plus difficile on supprime des
trottoirs multiplie les embûches pour le
piéton piétons devient naître terrorisé
poursuivi donc on essaye d'éliminer
cette part je dirais pas naturel mais
cette part évidente cette part réelle de
l'homme pour lui
pour la remplacer par l'homme d'argent
par l'homme profiteurs et dont on
profite c'est à dire que i les
profiteurs parce qu'ils profitent en
effet des biens matériels se déplacent
en voiture c'est plus pratique quand il
pleut mais en même temps on profite de
lui parce que tout est fait pour
l'obliger à avoir une voiture et ça fait
partie donc un système sans alors je
suis intéressé parce qu'ils réagissent
contre sympa les mendiants sont des gens
actuellement qui ont une forme de
courage parce qu'ils le veulent ils
ils réussissent à sauver un mode de vie
qui est pas du tout adapté à cette
société j'avais eu nous poser cette
question est-ce qu'il est plus important
de connaître le nom des plantes le nom
des aigles nom des insectes que de
connaître tous les titres des livres
d'une bibliothèque
c'est peut-être pas tout à fait la même
chose mais enfin je crois que il faut
les deux c'est à dire que si possible
avoir un petit peu de chaque c'est pas
important de connaître tellement de
choses en fin de compte ce qui est pas
un c'est pas important de sedan
d'emmagasiner des choses mais de
connaître les choses qui vont vous
servir alors connaître tous les noms de
les livres d'une bibliothèque ça ne peut
pas vous servir
mais connaître les noms des livres qui
vous ont ému enfin connaître des livres
qui vous ont émis fils ont fait du bien
et connaître aussi des plantes et
reconnaître les arbres et savoir ce qui
se passe dans les arbres printemps c'est
aussi une chose importante ne peux pas
me semble qu'on ne peut pas
ce serait artificielle de sacrifier l'un
pour fido
j'aimerais qu'on me parliez un des
arbres deux des nuages parce que il ya
beaucoup d'arbres beaucoup de nuages
dans mon heure les arbres bien qu'elle
n'a pas dans le désert c'est vrai mais
mais il ya tout de même certains arbres
la périphérie du désert
et puis c'est le sait la recherche de
l'ombre pour ceux qui ont soif pour ceux
qui ont eu très chaud dans la journée et
pourquoi y at-il tant d'arbres bien
d'abord dans le désert via des arbres
c'est lorsqu'on cesse d'être dans le
désert qu'on arrive dans l'oasis par
exemple est ce assez
c'est sensible on parlait tout à l'heure
du yucatan de l'endroit où espace
laventure dé séparer des mayas il ya en
effet une explosion de verdure une
explosion de vie à chaque fois qu'il ya
un peu d'eau et on sent à ce moment là
quel point c'est important à quel point
le l'arbre est un un symbole les mêmes
signes d'une importance extraordinaire
pour l'âme
on ne peut pas être content on ne peut
pas être heureux si on n'a pas senti
cette force du végétal vivants oui mais
je me souviens de roger caillois me
disait un jour que lorsqu'il est allé en
amérique latine notamment en amazonie et
bien les arbres paix est fait peur car
d'un seul coup il s'est dit cette nature
est terrifiante
oui oui je comprends ça a un effet ya un
sentiment d'oppression mais ce moment là
ce ne sont plus les arbres c'est une
sorte de désert d'armes
c'est à dire qu' on ne peut plus on ne
voit plus vraiment là on voit une masse
végétale mur végétal duquel l'homme est
expulsé c'est un petit peu au fond le
désert parce que le désert et terrifiant
par son côté minéral et la forêt la
selve amazonienne et terrifiante par son
côté compact et austin et étrangers
alors les nuages il y a quelques années
je vous avais demandé de faire pour la
télévision un petit film d'une dizaine
de minutes à votre choix votre goût à
votre humeur et ils vous aviez fait fini
dont le sujet principal c'était les
nuages dans l'arrière-pays niçois
c'est pourquoi avez vous choisi ce sujet
bah quand j'étais enfant j'aimais bien
me coucher sur le dos et regarder passer
les nuages c'était une de mes activités
et les voir se transformer prendre des
formes extraordinaires s'unir ou bien
s'allonger
il ya une vie ordinaire dans les nuages
ils sont ils sont vivants ils sont
libres et sont libres bien entendu il
n'y a pas de frontière qui les arrêtent
ils vont où ils veulent oui m'enfin les
nuages ils sont poussés par le vent
et ils n'y peuvent rien contre le vent
ils ont traversé par des avions ne
demande pas leur avis temps en temps ils
sont transformés en grêle en neige et en
pluie ils savent même pas pourquoi c'est
pas ça la liberté oui ici la liberté
c'est quand même de pouvoir glisser dans
le vent c'est à dire la liberté c'est
d'être portés par le vent même si on est
traversé par un avion en avion ce n'est
pas gênant c'est pas n'est guère plus
gênant que 15 oiseaux qui passent à face
et c'est tout petit un avion vous
aimeriez de poussée par les nuages
oui j'aimerais bien en effet c'est un
cetain revo fond je crois que le
véritable rêve de l'homme s'est pas de
voler comme un oiseau c'est de voler
comme un nuage c'est-à-dire de glisser
sans bruit et sans effort comme un
planeur un petit peu mais le planeur
soumis à la pesanteur alors que le nuage
n'est pas soumis aux besoins peur jmg le
clézio
je veux savoir si si vous lisez les
autres et qui va notamment les écrivains
français contemporains
oui je lis je lis je lis aussi des
manuscrits je lui des romans qui n'ont
pas été publiés bon parce que voudrait
qu'ils ont mais hier non non on passa
nommé je suis assez intéressé et enfin
c'est depuis longtemps on m'envoie des
manuscrits et je suis assez touchés par
le par ce qui se fait actuellement
les tentatives par exemple de sortir un
petit peu du du roman traditionnel
d'exprimer autre chose
et puis j'étais touchée aussi par le
roman américain sont les livres qui
m'ont le plus m'ont apporté le plus sûr
mais je me souviens d'une déclaration
vous aviez fait à mes confrères il ya
plusieurs années vous disiez que vous
n'étiez pas très à l'aise quand vous
lisiez un lit parce que vous deviez le
lire d'une seule traite et que oui je
continue je continue à dire comme ça je
sais pas trop je ne suis pas très à
l'aise parce que c'est un petit peu
fatigant j'ai une tension lorsque je
prends un livre je ne lâche pas si je le
lâche c'est mauvais signe c'est que je
n'aurai pas envie de me remettre
pourquoi le pensec la lecture c'est un
corps à corps qui n'est moyens je crois
que c'est pas vraiment un corps à corps
mais c'est une sorte de communion avec
la personne qui a écrit et si on si on
lâche un instant ou si on lâche trop
longtemps on risque de ne plus être un
peu minutes et vous recommanderiez de
lire vos livres de cette façon je ne
sais pas mais je crois que j'aimerais
bien être lus en étant feuilleter pas
possible c'est à dire non je veux dire
en partant en passant d'un passage à
l'autre en allant d'un moment à l'autre
en en voyageant un petit peu à travers
le livre on peut le faire par exemple
pour les trois villes saintes ne veut
pas le faire pour désert il me semble
que s'il me semble que si ça devrait
pouvoir se faire
enfin j'aime c'est une idée que
j'aimerais je ne suis pas sûr que ce
soit possible mais j'aimerais bien lire
comme ça
animal souvent de lire un livre de cette
façon c'est à dire de liant un passage
vers le milieu puis vers la fin et puis
d'aller au début et puis de faire la
jonction et quelquefois de relire c'est
à dire d'avoir une approche
un petit peu compliqué de vivre je suis
sûr que les gens qui vous écoute là
doivent se dire combien le clézio et
déroutant combien il est laid
difficilement cernable mais c'est pas ce
n'est pas déroutant du tout parce que je
suis sûr que quand vous étiez enfant
vous lisiez comme cela c'est à dire que
vous ne commencez pas par le début et on
ne suivait pas jusqu'à la fin mais vous
alliez quelquefois ou sautier des pages
pour voir ce qui allait se passer et
puis vous vous revenir en arrière et
vous alliez aux illustrations aussi
peut-être autrement dit je ne suis pas
resté un enfant alors que vous vous
l'êtes rester mais je ne suis pas sûre
vous ne disiez pas comme une lisez pas
encore comme cela non non non j'ai pas
comme ça mais c'est peut-être l'édition
actuelle qui ne s'y prête pas moi je
pense aux livres de jules verne par
exemple qui j'ai beaucoup aimé ça quand
j'étais enfant et il y avait on suivait
de d'illustrations en illustration il y
avait dans la collection et elle c'était
très facile à suivre et on pouvait ainsi
aller 20 milieu sous les mers on pouvait
faire le voyage d'une façon pas
chronologique mais affective en allant
voir les animaux qui vous intéressait un
peu comme on lit le dictionnaire russie
mais c'est vrai il a je suis très
sérieux quand je le dis c'est vrai que
vous êtes resté un enfant
oui j'espère c'est une chose que
j'aimerais ça ne peut pas être
volontairement comme cela mais en fait
ce que j'aimerais c'est retrouver cela
il me semble que l'effort et me sens que
c'est un peu pour ça que j'écris semble
que l'effort de quelqu'un qui crie c'est
pour retrouver celui qui l'était c'est
n'ont pas retrouvé son passé n'ont pas
retrouvé le temps perdu mais retrouver
des émotions retrouver des instants
retrouvez dès dessine de l'époque où il
a commencé à connaître le monde où il a
commencé à commencer à vivre vraiment et
oui là peut-être les moments où il a le
plus vécu avec le plus d'intensité pour
appeler y est ce que vous avez écrit
dans l'inconnu sur terre c'était je veux
écrire et se terminer ainsi
je vous écris pour une aventure libre
sans histoire sans issue une aventure de
terre d'eau et d'air où il n'y aurait à
jamais que les animaux les plantes et
les enfants je vais écrire pour une vie
nouvelle de toujours dans cet état
d'esprit
oui c'est pour moi le sens même de
l'écriture s'est trouvée s'est trouvé
l'homme nouveau qu'on a en soi c'est à
dire retrouver l'enfant ancien puisque
l'homme nouveau c'est l'enfant siens
c'est cette union entre le passé et le
futur
contrairement à le clézio borgès lui
adore parler donner des interviews on
raconte même quinze jours à buenos aires
un journal humoristique est paru avec ce
titre exceptionnellement dans ce numéro
pas d'interview de borgès borgès est à
lui seul une tour de babel
il parle de nombreuses langues il sait
tout les étymologies toutes les
littératures
il approfondit toutes les cultures une
babel sans fenêtre puisqu'il est aveugle
une feu une babel vieillissant puisqu'il
à 80 non mais une babel sans désordre
rigoureuse qui a gardé attaque sa
fabuleuse mémoire et son inlassable
curiosité et qui respire la culture
comme d'autres simplement respire
l'oxygène l'univers de borgès les livres
et les mots et à travers les mots par
delà leur sens et leur musique nous
faisons irruption dans la poésie le
fantastique et la métaphysique jamais
les mots ont été plus aimé que par
l'argentin borgès jorge luis borgès nous
sommes ici à la fondation simone et cino
del duca vous avez reçu le prix mondial
jean odel du cas pour l'ensemble de
votre oeuvre c'était donc un prix de
couronnement et il y a à peu près 20 ans
vous avez reçu un fermenteur le
un prix international de littérature qui
est elle a aussi décerné par des
intellectuels français et il ya vingt
ans c'était notamment il y avait roger
caillois le regretté enfin c'est l'homme
qui vous a découvert et lancé en france
si l'on peut dire
et donc il ya vingt ans c'était un prix
de découverte aujourd'hui donc c'est un
prix de consécration et vous avez donc
votre tête a reçu beaucoup de lauriers
littéraire et c'est arrivé
et puis ça nous arrivait en espagne je
suppose pas du ski en argentine
probablement pas chanter vous avez reçu
ma le chemin je n'ai pas changé d'avis
ensuite vous n'avez encore rien vu
nous sommes très discret oui ça peut
venir ça peut venir des mots six mois
oui ça peut venir à venir est infinie
mais enfin cette pratique des prix
littéraires remonte comme vous le savez
à l'antiquité grecque est ce que vous y
êtes favorable dans mon cas j'ai aussi
ses prix de maths études émotions je ne
suis pas dit jeannot si j'ai oublié ma
je reçois même avis demain il sera
rejoint d'autres cours est entrepris
êtes le vrai prix chez le fait de lire
réfléchir le rêvait de prémédité et
découvre ensuite c'est exceptionnel
là les mêmes et puis d'être lu c'est la
passion contagieuse jamais donateurs
quand j'écris j'écris des champs pour
s'engager
j'écris au bout et s'est libéré d'un
sujet je ne cherche pas de thème le
thème et cherche alors un des thèmes
insiste je tâcherai l'écrire puis une
fois que je l'écris cela me donne
beaucoup de la peine
il ya toujours bien des brouillons de
rire au fond de chaque match que je crie
puis cas je l'écris je ne publie vous
penser autre chose et quand j'ai vu me
un livre tu l'oubli son succès au
recomptage mais je ne m'intéresse pas je
passe toujours à ce que je vais écrire
c'est que j'écris je laisse derrière moi
ce sont des brouillons tout simplement
alors j'ai lu le livre qui va paraître
chez gallimard et qui se termine par une
essai d'autobiographie d'environ une
cinquantaine de pages jeu si vous voulez
on va avoir un peu parler de ce que vous
dites dans celui dans ce tour et c'est
ce que j'ai dit et chez dc un ami à moi
je m'arme à damas et joanie sélectif et
pour le public de new york
donc je racontais bien des choses que
tout le monde connaît chez moi mais
j'écris celle là j'étais bourré m'a dit
qu'un je n'ai pas relu mais je pense que
pas mal non et l'état très intéressant
parce qu'on apprend à vous connaître et
par exemple vous dit ceci bien j'ai de
très bonnes heures u11 d'être quelqu'un
aimant que les livres au lieu d'être un
homme d'action
oui oui mais après ça je ne partage pas
ses opinions là à gérard aschieri faire
quelque chose c'est peut être moi qui
réfléchisse ou de rêver quelque chose je
vois 4ème écrivain est une belle
destinée oui mais c'était aussi un homme
d'action est un écrivain
oui maintenant données fournies par face
à l'action passera au plaisir d'écrire
aux problèmes décrire évidemment
cheikh étaient les militaires qui se
sont battus même qui sont morts mais
après ça je pense que peut être la vie
il était moins riche que la mienne ne
mangez pas ça elle je m'assois bien
d'autres choses tandis qu'il n'en fait
agir oui mais je remarque dans votre
dans cet essai de biographique que vous
racontez que votre père a voulu que vous
deveniez écrivain alors que la plupart
des jeunes quand ils me donnaient un
écrivain c'est contre leurs parents
alors classé sur l'exhortation de votre
père vous êtes devenu mon père voulait
être un calvin il n'a pas lu alors il
m'a fait hériter cette destinée qui
n'est pas atteint il a fait ça exprès
puis je me suis élevé dans la
bibliothèque de mon père c'est que j'ai
appris ailleurs n'est pas important mais
vous avez aussi hérité de votre père la
cécité vigiles aveugle comme le thym
depuis 1955 puis après tout cela était
alors qu'airbus qu ils n'eurent qu'un
moment pathétique
puis un peu une chose se sont éloignés
de moi après ça il n'y ait eu de vagues
fort je sais même pas si ce front semble
lui être vous ou verdâtre et aujourd'hui
un moment il est de couleur que je perdu
le rouge et le noir je vois le rouge le
noir comme bras oui mais je trouve ça
extraordinaire quand on y réfléchit
que vous ayez eu un père qui était qui
avait la volonté de devenir écrivain et
qui est lui-même est devenu aveugle peu
à peu et qui donc a eu ce fils qui est
vous qui a et écrivain et qui lui aussi
devenu aveugle peu à peu une espèce de
symétrie magique non oui c'est ça oui
c'est ça c'est le symétrique nom et est
ce que nous sommes légèrement se brûler
est-ce que nous ne sommes pas là dans le
le fameux labyrinthe borgésien oui
j'aime et pourquoi pas peut-être le
monde attend la vilaine n'en savons rien
mais bhl idée de la villa 7-1
consolation parce que au sat parce que
la ville entend centre tandis que mange
avons passé le monde un centre j'étais
un peu surpris monsieur bergé de voir
que vous preniez la plupart des livres
que vous avez écrit durant votre
jeunesse
j'ai commencé par erreur par exemple
j'ai commencé par le vers libre
le vers libre et très difficile sur le
rythme pur et simple
je voulais il faut commencer par une
forme classique qui sont plus faciles à
dar el hani si vous arrivez sur un
sévère revers libre alors vous n'êtes
qu'un guide
je vous concède en forme cela vous êtes
vous commencez dix ans en france et par
alexandra un espagnol depuis la sellette
par le verre de rouge syllabes louis
gillet brute s'élève à 7
mais tout le monde commet l'erreur que
j'ai commise on passe d'une verge livre
est plus facile il est très difficile
comme la proscrit physique une verge
dîner est ce que je retiens de ce que
voulait dire c'est que vous reniez ce
livre non pas à cause des idées que vous
exprimer mais à cause de la forme oui
oui un constat la forme ici des choses
un peu près le même jeu peu d'idées je
suis passé j'ai dit des nouvelles mais
lui demain à présent nos apprentis chers
vous êtes arrivé à l'âge de 80 ans
juste appris quelque chose au fond vous
êtes un esthète qui rognait les premiers
pas d'un jeune homme qui était aussi un
esthète exactement est sauf que quand
j'étais un jeune homme
je te donne ce titre d'une façon
générale est il que certains cherchent
n'a atteint tandis que prochain jeu
je tâche de plus avec une chance j'étais
aussi jeter acheter
je n'ai pas pensé à des théories je
tâche tout simplement d'être humains
dans un conte un fable de composer un
poème je pense pas aux tueries lundi le
tessin je voulait épater le bourgeois
qui n'est plus imbattable oui damas je
voulais surprendre
je voulais je voyais ça la possibilité
d'inventer des métaphores
maintenant je crois qu'il n'y a que j'ai
pas de médecin de métaphores essentiel
qu'on ne peut rien faire sauf
d'évaluation pour raconter très bien que
jeune homme vous vouliez absolument vous
faire lire et vous vous dites vous
lorsque vous avez écrit un
recueil de poèmes ou un poème je ne sais
pas qui s'appelle ferveur de buenos
aires s'est arrêté publié ou ici
longtemps 1923 et là vous avez inventé
un stratagème pour vous faire lire
vous vous rappelez un régime oui j'ai
laissé mon bouquin dans la poche c'est
savait déjà que je ne vois là oui vous
êtes il y avait un restaurant où il y
avait beaucoup de critiques et d'actions
en vue de leur chargement aux autres
alors je priais le directeur de glisser
un exemplaire dans tous les manteaux oui
oui des têtes aux vestiaires yamato aux
études a effectivement c'est une bonne
tactique et j'habite à mes moutons en
lui le voilà à tellement ils ont trouvé
bon oui moi je trouve que jouer les
jeunes poètes français devrait retenir
ce stratagème parce qu'il avait rendu un
chapelet bon mais le alors vous avez
parlé de la bibliothèque de votre père
mais ensuite vous avez eu accès à deux
autres bibliothèques une bibliothèque
municipale vous étiez un petit
fonctionnaire
et puis ensuite la bibliothèque b2b
lozère dont vous avez été le directeur
j'ai quitté mon poste je sais que
monsieur non j'ai dit le texte
mais même moi je préfère le souvent
raconté sur cette bibliothèque
municipale vous étiez à un employé
subalterne
j'ai beaucoup de bien oui il travaillait
fort j'ai lu tous les livres de claudel
et tout le livre des télés en vouloir
quitter la vue le texte destiné à jour y
est je sais pas pourquoi j'ai trouvé ce
livre là qui nous veulent du bien de
livrer mais vous ne travaillez pas
beaucoup à ses débuts en avant tient
qu'à raqqa prix on n'avait rien à faire
absolument rien à part c'est formidable
alors les bougies gagné 250 pesos c'est
qui signifie quelque chose
après sera évidemment cela ne signifie
rien notre monnaie nous vaut rien mais
ce qui est extraordinaire c'est qu'on
pourrait raconter votre vie simplement
par des bibliothèques parle d'abord la
bibliothèque de votre père ensuite cette
petite bibliothèque municipale et
ensuite à bibliothèque nationale si je
vous ferais même si c'est une belle idée
oui je suis jamais eu le vainqueur
surtout il faudra si c'est trash écrit
un poème sur saône à un ancien directeur
bibliothèque peut-être grimpe l'hiver
français il refuse un espagnol inconnu
en france
pour bruce est qu il était directeur
hugues de thé cavern
et moi j'ai hérité ces deux choses assez
cité la direction de teck écrit un poème
sur sol un elle s'appelle au m2 dont
vous connaissez parquet non mais je le
dis je suis pas trop sûr qui écrit ce
poème se sert du sac ou moins assez
longtemps sont les mêmes mais ne vous
inquiétez plus courageux que moi il
n'est pas ce que je bois puis j'ai
découvert qu'il y ait eu à notre
directeur à vendre ou shakira moi qui
étais aussi dit aussi veulent c'est une
cible dynastie mais je pensais pas qu'il
ya alors vraiment sur le destiner une
sorte de
de fatalité de main de dieu parce que
cette filiation avec votre père cette
filiation de bibliothécaire aveugle mais
nous avons trouvé des zones noires
symétrique l'un et huit la cécité
les bibliothèques tout cela tous les
bords tout cela cyborg toutes et tous
des sables déjà il invente et je
remercie
oui mais en même temps tu essaies perçu
du vin faso où elle avait dit de façon
précise ce beau matin oui mais en même
temps il sait il ya en même temps une
contradiction extraordinaire et pro
vente puisque une bibliothèque elle est
faite de livres qui doivent être lues et
que donc tous et bibliothécaires ne
pouvait pas voir et ne pouvait donc pas
lire
bien qu'elle ait quelque chose de
magique sans doute fausse le faut si qui
je continue à acheter les livres je ne
peux pas les lire mais la présence de
livres med savent c'est gravitation
silencieuse s'intitule diverses il ya
moi je ne peux pas lui mais je ne veux
pas la lire il est là je le possède
mais si vous abusez avignon bibliothèque
je me rappelle que scénique
née dans une de ces les traire à lui
s'il s'est moqué de monsieur
contemporaine qui est le titre de son
livre en disant que personne n'a le
temps de lire ce livre c'est une vanité
risque tout le monde à la bibliothèque
je dois dire celui qui n'a pas l'air si
la rue est à lire la moitié des livres
j'ai chez moi je lui dis moi ce qui me
fascine chez vous monsieur borgès entre
autres c'est votre
passion permanente omniprésente je
dirais quasiment forcené pour les
langues pour les littératures pour les
grammaires pour les étymologies et à ce
propos dans ce texte qui va paraître
vous raconter ce si un collègue
académiciens me prête un jour à paris me
dit inquiet que peut bien signifier ce
poème de vous publier sous le titre en
route pour l'étude de la grammaire anglo
saxon j'essayais de lui faire comprendre
que l'anglo saxon était pour moi une
expérience aussi émouvante que d'admirer
un coucher de soleil de tomber amoureux
est-ce que vous n'exagérez pas un peu
noté j'aime beaucoup les mois à nicollin
pas trop le synology surtout les
aventures de man il vous pensez que les
aventures d'un mot c'est aussi important
que la une aventure amoureuse
en tout cas il est bien plus longue
nous aussi être par exemple eh bien vous
d'appel du mot hasard régulière du rhume
à l'armée non un coup de dés jamais
n'abolira le hasard non exactes vient le
moins ça signifie des jeux 2d est un
dream au logis le mot sinon c'est la
nausée
oui l'anoci est à moi c'est désagréable
mais ils nomment leur origine cela vient
des na'vis du navire sans dan aussi
canon le thabor coin pour le mal de mer
donc le mono chez les mi-lourds jdt
navale
cette nouvelle alliance du mot logique
personnelle de vide parce qu'ils le
trouvaient évidente qu'on lettre volée
et impôts clément bande à nos bonnets au
oui de bongolo cdu longue méchant en
bois d'un fruit d'or oui volonté mais
regrette c'est la série d'aquarelles
pas du tout et bien je vous aiderai été
par cheikh de tigres seraient ce teaser
assez bien du bagel exactement la
première personne ne soit universelle
qui trouvent cela m'avait prédit bengo
benga les bengals en espagnol de bangolo
c'est une chance et bien je vous
félicite
merci beaucoup c'est sûr question il y à
tartas que je pose cette question bouche
de le premier buteur je vais mettre ça
sur mes cartes de visite mais il va
découvrir à mes amis et gilles lapouge
qui avait écrit un très très beau et
très bel article sur vous a dit de vous
que vous étiez le champion du vertige
métaphysique champions c'est un peu fort
je ne pas être champion
non mais bon le vertige métaphysique oui
c'est bon mais je ne me rappelle je
mangerai alléchante écrit et l'origine
la philosophie c'était l'étonnement au
président les choses ne vont rien n'est
pas alors commencé à faire le bruit de
l'eau sophie d'un fleuron ses hommes
je vous laisse donc vertige bon mais
qu'est ce que c'est que le vertige
métaphysique
si je m'étais fait sic je sens tout le
temps de plus en plus simple je ne suis
pas tout à fait sûr d'être à paris de
coucher avec vous tout ceci ne fait pas
c'est votre rêve qui s'appelle ma vie ou
peut-être cet autre rêve je peux
l'univers vous le passé j'ai insulté
tout le temps des surprises
je m'étonne de choses comme un enfant
vous n'êtes jamais sûr
au fond de la réalité du moment sauf
dans deux cas car enfin du plaisir
physique et la douleur physique aussi de
la campanera jobin et aucun doute il
faut y croire
sauf dans le cas de la douleur et du
plaisir physique wii et d'autres cas oui
pour savourer ça le goût dès lors qu'ils
visitent aussi et de ton moral oui mais
je vous fais remarquer que vous avez
vous buvez le loews lorsque les caméras
marché que le vin vous l'avez vu quand
les caméras ne marchaient pas ouais j'ai
voulu donner du courage je trek
j'ai encore un peu le trac alors dans ce
petit texte va vous parler un petit peu
de la france où vous n'êtes pas très
tendre avec avait avec les français
celui une phrase qui m'a fait que woerth
et beaucoup de français vous dites que
vous trouvez le français finalement que
langue que vous pratiquez admirablement
mais vous dit le français aussi vous dit
que le français est une langue un peu
vulgaire j'ai passé je me suis assis
sinon je n'aime pas les sons du français
mais la littérature la poésie qu'on a
fait avec son admirable
ah oui c'est à dire je crois par charles
chercher un seul point et sauver ou
peut-être hugo ou peut-être les bonnes
chansons de dollars vous pensez que les
les poètes français yves antennes et un
de mes amis personnels oui il ne vous
quitte jamais montaigne non ne me dit
pas si je ne passe en france c'est
l'habitude de cénacles l'excès de
publicité monsieur lèvres un peu partout
dans le monde sur wii mais vous trouvez
d'autant plus admirable finalement la
littérature française qu'elle a été fait
à partir d'une langue commune estime est
pas tout à fait remarquable qui venait
pas le son du frac chez eux vers les
simples certains trop gore puis a perdu
loyer ouverte thani l'espagnol n'est pas
trop beau mais je regardais nourrir
ouverte
le latin et l'italien si oui quel
français
c'est plus riches je n'ai plus 20 ans
c'est tout l'art des des consomment
plutôt curiel la glisse même source
l'ancien glamour je ressens juste une
blague avant tout à elle tout simple je
dis l'air vraiment fils bob hormats
bureaux neufs mais vrai les offres et à
ea ferions qu'une la vie snedai a fait
installer car outre à cannes et frais ou
des consonnes il paraît que l'anglais
les shakespeare a fait encore doyelle ce
vieux nous disent aujourd'hui que be or
not to be temps dit il paraît qu'elle
shakespeare m'a dit évidemment c'est une
hypothèse qui descend tard 17e siècle
indice est tombé ornato vert or natalie
wyeth après ça on a perdu les voyages et
la musique est restée là mystérieusement
alors est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
les critiques français afin qu'un
quelques critiques qui dit votre
inventaire non la loi qui dise de vous
guise de vos nouvelles de vos comptes
qui disent de vos poèmes que vous vous
adressez sans ciellement à l'esprit à
l'imagination à la mémoire à l'âme mais
que nous adresser pas au coeur ils vont
à l'école et une métaphore l'âme aussi
même s'ils disent que je m'adresse à la
marche et malgré son coeur aussi des
ventes il raison oui sur le champ dans
les chances que je ne veux pas être
sentimental je suis continuellement dans
ma vie surtout les classes j'écris je
tâche de ne pas l'être penser qu'un
écrivain doit pas être sentimental n'ont
en tout cas pas par moi dans sa salle
devant la roma mais dans sa vie
malheureusement on était gentiment tel
autre superstitieux vous pensez que
lorsque les que le poète lorsque le
compteur se met à sa table de travail
il doit laisser les sentiments dehors
mais je volerais les châtiments
adaptateur allume et non pas d'une
fraîcheur et son second appel
en direct je vais montrer voilà
qu'aujourd'hui moins de transformer en
métaphores fable chocolat qui toute
manoeuvre être autobiographique
je racontais ma vie à la déguisant ou
any more words d'achat de but de créer
des mythes mais ce camp où il à masquer
à aller sur le sable cette histoire que
je crie à sa source savoir si dans son
expérience personnelle que je ne pas
confier aux lecteurs personnes là le
voit des phrases de godasses mais je lui
racontais sous une forme et chars
allégoriques métaphorique mais que toute
manoeuvre à sa racine dans l'émotion je
ne conçois pas la littérature comme
enjeu de moi avec mon congé logique
je crois que c'est un poème navas a un
sentiment vers lui je vois sentiments
cachés et cela ne vaut rien mais rien
dit mais vous voulez dire que cette
émotion ne doit pas être livrés d'une
manière brute elle doit être créé
retravailler oui je veux des sciences et
le métier ou plutôt survolé sa femme au
plus ambitieux la destinée de l'écrivain
et de changer les choses
quel est ce que enfin celle d'informer
en beauté ce qu'il peut j'ai même
l'impression que tout ce qui m'arrive
même les mahler ou plutôt c'est surtout
le malheur mais sans donner pour que je
change quelque chose et c'est pour cela
qu'il y avait un doute et le trouble
email à lui m'a l'air pas les atours du
bonheur sèche parce que le bonheur est
enfant elle même tandis que les manières
doit être en chemin quelques jours notre
dans cette ville de jos dans cela ce
pourrait être la musique
se pourrait il à partir dans mon cas ce
n'est qu'elle était
[Musique]